wenn eine Chicken Nuggets Soße auch
wieder leer ist dann mach dir doch
einfach selbst welche und zwar so viel
wie du willst und das ist gar nicht so
schwer ihr braucht einfach nur eine
kleine Vielfalt von Zutaten und zwar für
sich Konfitüre 70g 70 g
Aprikosenkonfitüre eine Prise
Knoblauchpulver 20 ml Weißweinessig
Agavendicksaft ein Teelöffel Maisstärke
ein Schuss Sojasoße und ein Teelöffel
Senf und damit wir keine Stückchen haben
durch mixen okay das soll schon gewesen
sein einmal aufgekocht nehmen wir es
runter von der Hitze und lassen es
abkühlen hier ist also die
selbstgemachte und das ist die von
McDonald's und wir schauen mal wie sie
im Vergleich Aussehen okay wow also viel
unterscheidet sich da auf jeden Fall
nicht das sieht schon mal gut aus jetzt
der einzige gültige Test Chicken Nugget
in die Homepage
okay krass und in Meckes ich würde sagen
wir sind zu 90% da aber zu 100 % ist das
auf jeden Fall nicht die Meckes Soße sie
schmeckt aber auf jeden Fall richtig gut
und ich würde sagen
[Musik]